what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and recently we have been closely
following the case of Jonathan majors
are Kang the Conqueror our big bad in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe sadly
Jonathan Majors was arrested on Saturday
this was apparently because of a
domestic dispute where he was charged
with some cases of assault which we do
have more information on today the
several things that he was charged with
but we actually have some very very good
news for the fans of Jonathan Majors
Jonathan Majors as lawyer has recently
spoken out and talked about what exactly
they are planning right now to prove
that Jonathan Majors is innocent he says
that they are putting things together
right now and these things will in turn
prove that Jonathan Majors is innocent
and is actually the victim in this case
now a lot has come out about Jonathan
Majors since this happened and again
we're trying to remain impartial in the
middle until everything comes to the
surface but it really seems like
everything now is about to be out there
and it looks like it is good news for
Jonathan Majors so let's break down this
new report about how the lawyer for
Jonathan Majors is about to prove that
he's innocent so he says and this report
is coming from people.com and they start
off by saying that yesterday on Monday
March 27th they actually obtained
documents from the Manhattan District
Attorney's office and they report that
these documents show that Majors 33
years old was charged with three counts
of assault in the third degree
aggravated harassment in the second
degree three counts of attempted assault
in the third degree and harassment in
the second degree after he was arrested
for an alleged domestic dispute on
Saturday now that all sounds really
really bad it does but like we mentioned
before in previous videos what has been
really interesting about this entire
thing is that Jonathan Majors won the
police game simply went with them he
didn't put up a fight he didn't resist
arrest he didn't make a scene nothing
like that he just simply went with them
and then not too long after that his law
lawyer stated that he was actually the
victim and that is actually what she
does here again as well she released a
new statement we'll get to that in just
a bit but to finish off what people.com
States the documents show they say the
victim told police that Majors allegedly
struck her about the face with an open
hand causing substantial pain and a
laceration behind her ear as well as
allegedly grabbing her hand and neck
causing bruising and substantial pain
but again even after all of this
happened Jonathan Majors his lawyer
Priya Chaudhary said this he has done
nothing wrong we look forward to
clearing his name and clearing this up
but here's where we find out a little
bit more about the situation that
happened his lawyer continued to say
this the incident came about because
this woman was having an emotional
crisis for which she was taken to a
hospital yesterday so she was saying
this on Saturday when he was arrested
she continued the NYPD is required to
make an arrest in these situations and
this is the only reason Mr Majors was
arrested we expect these charges to be
dropped soon and this is true now this
sheds a little bit of light on the
situation especially if you consider
what we found out yesterday that
Jonathan Majors actually called the cops
before this dispute happened he
apparently called the cops because he
was worried about the girl the woman
that is claiming was assaulted he called
the police before the assault actually
happened claiming that he was worried
about her he was apparently worried
about her mental state and now the
statement about the woman having an
emotional crisis seemingly lines up with
this statement about Jonathan Majors
calling the police because he was
worried about her mental state and here
are some other few statements that
Jonathan Majors his lawyer released that
make it seem like Jonathan Mages really
is innocent in this case including one
very interesting fact here for starters
she says that he is completely innocent
and is probably the victim of an
altercation with a woman he knows but
then she goes on to say this we are
quickly Gathering and presenting
evidence to the district attorney with
the expectation that all charges will be
dropped imminently this evidence
includes video footage from the vehicle
where this episode took place witness
testimony from the driver and others who
both saw and heard the episode and most
importantly and here's the kicker here's
the really big thing she says two
written statements from the woman
recanting these allegations meaning that
the woman who is claiming to be
assaulted by Jonathan Majors is
recanting that statement that he
assaulted her meaning she has taken it
back she written statements from her
stating that he did not assault her and
it sounds like there were actually quite
a lot of witnesses and his lawyer seems
to be very confident that they all say
he did not assault her so this is all
extremely good news for Jonathan Majors
if this is all true it's hard to
speculate on what could have happened
especially when he was concerned for
This Woman's mental state and she was
apparently involved in some sort of an
emotional crisis but if she really is
recanting what she said then Jonathan
major should be in the clear and no
charges should be held against him in
court now he goes to court on May 8th
and hopefully everything comes to light
then and if anything happens in between
of course we'll do an update video
letting you know what we hear so to
follow this and of course regular MCU
news be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news you
can always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf wolf
foreign